after D4 D5 and Bishop to G5 if you
manage to watch this video Until the End
then you are going to equip with a
lifetime solution to meet this tricky
shur troski line in less than 20
minutes here my recommendation is very
special ab6 immediately attacking this
bishop and white has two good
choices well apart from this if the
bishop goes to somewhere else let's say
Bishop to D2 then after E5 not only
black get a wonderful Center but a very
easy place play and this will completely
equalize the game at the opening stage
so NOP that's not a good idea and
accordingly the Top Choice is Bishop to
H4 where upon we are going to surprise
wide with this very rare but super
tactical move Knight to F6
where black planning of campaign is
straightforward you want to play Knight
to F5 and nap the bishop
pair okay as per the database white has
two major choices and amongst them E3
has been exclusively played here but
after Knight to F5 it doesn't matter
however white continue let's say Bishop
to G3 is a Top Choice we can simply
respond with
H5 and would you believe this position
is almost close to
losing well as I have shown by the
arrows white has three major choices but
neither of them are working here number
one Bishop to D3 Database Top Choice
immediately fails with the move
H4 and that poor Bishop is almost tra
here because if he he continue with
Bishop to F4 then this is a blunder guys
as after
G5 black is winning the piece at just
seventh move of the game as the
Counterattack G4 doesn't work here due
to some simple Knight retrieving move so
that after Bishop to G6 Knight to F7 yes
indeed black is winning the
piece white can take this dangerous
number night but the more or less
problem remains same after Bishop takes
F5 as after Bishop to F4 and G5 that
Bishop has been trapped down and the
only way to escape from this mass is to
play E4 a
Counterattack but black can simply take
this pawn and after some obvious
sequence F3 Bishop to F5 and Bishop to
E3 if you carefully count the material
yep indeed black has come out out as a
point advantage and the most surprising
part is if you look at the engine
Evolution here it says it's close to
completely winning for the
black third dangerous tactical move
white can try over here is Queen to G4
not only attacking this Knight twice but
there is a threat of Queen to G6 and at
first side looks very scary except black
has this nice tactical shot and that is
Knight to D6 where we are attacking the
queen and the Big Time point is after
Queen check and Knight to
F7 that Bishop has only one square to go
and after that what else this nice
winning shot did you find
it congratulations if you see the move
EA
what a move well you may say hang on but
that just drops the pawn because after
Pawn Tak and pawn ties white can simply
take on E5 as the Knight on F7 is spin
yes but here's the point you play Rook
to F6 and now forget about the pce White
Queen is a complete
goner
okay let's check out what we are going
to do against the move Bishop to E2 well
yep the same story you push the pawn and
White's main idea is he wants to give
this check and when our King get
misplaced now he has a choice how to
save the
bishop number one if he played the move
Bishop to F4 which is in fact a bad move
as after after
G5 that Bishop has been trapped down and
again to escape this he has to play E4
where black is more than happy to take
this Pawn so that after Bishop to D2 and
the move
C6 our King will be remain very safe on
the C7 and the matter of fact is black
is emerg with a clear Pawn advantage and
a dominating position how about Bishop
to G six which looks more natural first
of all you are hitting the Knight you
stopping Black to play the moon
G6 and for a moment it looks so good
except one problem that black can
straight away capture this
piece allowing white to gain his piece
back but after E6 Bishop to H3 Pawn
takes F2 King takes F2 and the move
C6 yes both the King has been misplaced
but I think it is black king who is more
safer than white along with the bishop
pair black get this open Edge file which
sums up a great advantage to the
black last probably the easiest move is
H3 as after this the sequence is very
obvious first you take this bishop
destroy the white Pawn structure and now
you attack this loose Pawn with Queen to
D6 well white can already go wrong here
if he played the move Queen to F3 as
this simply allows this wonderful check
and white lose some big material on the
Quin side so that is right out of the
equation I don't like the Moon Knight to
E2 because it's completely jam up the
white king side so by far the top choice
is to play kinging to F2 defending this
pawns but black is more than happy as he
continue with E5 and with the space in
the center and misplace King it is black
who get a completely great position out
of the opening
stage the second most popular choice is
to play F3 and against this my
recommendation is very simple you play
C5 and if your opponent continue with
moves such as E3 or C3 then as I
highlighted by the arrows black has a
wonderful
plan including hitting in the center so
the correct choice is to capture this
Pawn but after this I recommend this
straightforward approach you play E6
attacking this pawn and after Bishop to
F2 Knight to A6 confirms black opening
Advantage after some obvious sequence E4
and Bishop takes C5 white can already go
wrong here if he take on A6 because
black can First Take on F2 and the point
is after King takes and queen to B6 we
don't have to take with the pawn but we
will take back with the
queen so that's a bad choice and
accordingly here white should play
Bishop takes C5 but after Knight takes
C5 Pawn takes D5 if you don't want to
take too much risk I strongly insist you
to capture this Pawn back however if you
like me who want an attacking position
then Queen to B6 is a fitting
reply the point is you are hitting on B2
and after B3 now black can take on D5
and if allowed we'll play the move
Bishop to E6 and Castle either either
side but the big question comes what
happens if white take this Pawn well
this is what I like about this Gambit
line we continue with Bishop to E6 and
after Queen to D1 and
Castle just look at the white pieces
they are all sleeping and black is fully
developed not so surprising look at the
engine Evolution it says white should
pack his bag and go
home the second most popular choice here
is to play Bishop to F4 but this is just
a Tempo up London system version where
black get this F6 move free of charge
and the way black should take the
initiative is play the move
C5 of course you can't take this Pawn
because after E5 Bishop to G3 and Bishop
takes C5 black get wonderful Center and
and very easy play so that is right out
of the equation most of your opponent
will bolster this Pawn structure with
either the move E3 or C3 let's say E3 is
stop choice and against this you just
continue to pressurize the center with
Knight to C6 threat is E5 so white needs
to prevent it but exactly here I'm going
to recommend this very aggressive setup
and that start with G5 hitting this
bishop Bishop G3 and no price for
guessing next move yep
H5 and you know what we can already sets
up a small trap if white foolishly
continue with H4 as after G4 the D Pawn
is a complete gonner for example if we
play a knight to D2 then we can simply
take on D4 twice and become a pawn up so
that is right out of the equation most
of your opponent will continue with
Knight to G1 but this simply allowed the
move E5 and look at the space black is
gaining in the center and as I have
shown here by the arrows in which
opening you get such a dominating Center
at just within the few moves of the
opening
stage so that's why the correct move is
to play S3 preserving the bishop
whereupon to conclude this video on a
high note I like to show you a grandmas
game where black simply crush his high
rank opponent in a
style first he kickart with C captures
D4 please note white cannot take back
with the p
as after E5 black get the wonderful
Center so rightly so in the game white
plays e captures D4 but this simply
allow this wonderful night
maneuvering and time and time again in
this line you are going to see Knight to
F5 okay in the game white continue with
Bishop to D3 trying to control the F5
black says no sweee I'm going to come on
F5 and anyways and the problem from the
white side is he simply cannot move the
bishop in the view of
G4 Knight to G1 and now simple chess
take on D4 with a healthy Pawn
Advantage so that is the reason why at
this point white obliged to take on fi
but after Bishop takes F5 the threat is
Queen to
B6 so white conquered this with
C3 but after this I really like every
move of the black just look at this guys
first H4 hitting the bishop Bishop to H2
now he play Queen to D7 stopping any
kingside Castle as there's a sacrifice
looming on H3 so white thought no
problem I'm going to go on the quein
side with Knight to D2 and after black
castles Queen to E2 sets up the platform
for the quinide
castle okay black says you are too slow
and I will play G4 so that after Pawn
takes G4 and Bishop takes G4 yes you
allow white to Castle on the quein side
but after Bishop to
H6 every single black piece is on the
optimum
Square well would you believe the next
move of the white king to B1 turn out as
a big time blunder yes it doesn't look
like right but see
yourself Queen to F5 check King to H1
and now this wonderful move Bishop takes
D2 decide the
game the point is after Rook captures D2
and the mo H3 it doesn't matter how we
white plays he is going to lose a piece
well he tried Queen to D3 but the Grand
Master see the sequence
instantly and I hope you had seen it as
well first exchain the queen then take
on G2 and now Rook is hanging Knight is
hanging Bishop is hanging every single
thing is hanging and the fact is after
Rook moves black Chop on F3 and then
Chop on H2 which give him not only a
clear piece Advantage but there is a the
Monster Pawn sitting on G2 and seeing
all this white simply resigned the
game that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful tricky line against
the pseudo troski attack I am sure after
watching this video you really want to
try this in your own game well best of
luck for it but before you go please
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this video and I will meet you soon
in my next
lecture bye and take
care